hi sup bros what is x2o why what is what
does happening launches you oh oh
there's bugs oh okay okay
oh god I've forgotten how stupid this
game is good we're stuck in a hole yep
I've I remember so that X is like an
extra boost you can give yourself a free
double jump oh that's helpful
yeah oh why isn't that in the normal
game I don't know oh my god yeah look at
that oh I killed it a shotgun oh oh we
have an attack I'm killing everything in
here man attack the the X is like an
attack I think that's what you meant
right mark yes the only thing you can do
way that's different is the attack I'm
dead well you're dead we've hearts well
maybe you shouldn't have squandered your
chances oh I'm dead yeah
the the crystals or that purple square
oh whoa destructible levels oh there's
something down there a chest what the
hell
Pogo suck platformer what is this yeah
it's like a month old it was like a
dungeon crawler and so now what do we do
yeah how do we know we got to go to that
that door ah I did it I'm the winner
no oh Ling on a key oh yeah I hold the
key
wait wait wait wait wait that's the
problem Oh oh boy Alfred
okay I killed the purple thing now is
causing us damage oh my god oh did I
kill her did I just shoot sure I boomed
myself into the crystals what what's
happened I oh we have no we're dead oh
oh cool
hey what did I just get I guess got a
pencil I don't know what I got either oh
wait I got nothing well I got a laser
sight that's what I got
Frick wowee oh it shows you what you're
aiming at Oh
frickin there's a coin up there I don't
think I can good I'm just gonna give up
on that one up there what the hell I
don't know I just double jumped I like
can't get myself in the hole you see up
here where's Serena up oops okay I did
it
hi what's up friends I'm here man good
I'm dead
no the crystals bad hey oh yeah what's
up there how do I get you got it thank
you you can gain momentum by jumping and
double jumping and then super tips tell
him all about the flips shoot the thingy
shoot the golden rat thing or whatever
guys it Wow
some good stuff I Sarah I'm at the door
should I are we still exploring Ornish
surely there's some gold up here we're
still getting got it oh nevermind whoa
there was a bunch of gold in here that I
collected as well yeah I think we're
good go for it
wait yeah oh yeah this is dope it's like
an actual fun game I know it's like a
whole game there's bouncy mushrooms holy
[ __ ] oh I got triple jump this is gonna
get me in trouble
oh god it is it's I guaranteed get a
fancy mushroom let's see how bad things
are down here oh my god there's so many
bad things down here oh I'm dead I'm
dead
please I have it up how do I get out of
my bubbles Oh someone has to get me out
of my booth
bleh I'm a baby let's go find well can
you control which way you go oh you can
where'd you wait oh hey well thanks and
you uh don't pop me wait I'm trying
desperately not to get caught under this
thing the other small pup there's a
problem the crystal it really hurts
go please I just want to go okay this is
much harder than I thought it would be
please don't crash me Oh God
oh my god it's oh geez
okay this is actually a lot more
difficult and oh god I'm sorry
hey the chest said heart in it I'm sorry
lives work it was shared I really
struggled on that one I don't know why I
could not do this oh boy okay
no not that way oh my god this whole
double jump I'm not about it I don't
remember just don't use it as a jump use
it as a weapon and jump normally I have
three I got triple jump I'm gonna you
know armadillos I have to use it I have
to know I don't feel like that's not
true
yeah I have to oh god I got a hit I'm
sorry I'm sorry guys I'm real bad okey
skadoosh
I'm okay guys there's no mark did you
get them all no I kind of hey what's up
bro thank you I got the heart got it all
right is that all the things we out of
here yeah oh yeah let's get outta here
man if this gets harder as it goes on
we're gonna say I love this okay I love
it oh god no I'm sorry I'm sorry guys
I'm sorry
Oh get that coin up there I got you I
got you
oh no fine no please what did I get I
got some DNA thing I don't know I also
have that I think we're all getting all
the power-ups I'm not sure
no okay god I am having a rough time
oh god please is there actually like the
dog us two are also not taking damage
and dying two things I'm just I'm having
a real rough go fit and I from some
reason I feel like I'm bringing us all
down oh my god oh god this character
really desperately wants to go to this
blue crystal that's up here but I really
I'm really struggling good I thought it
was gonna be fun and easy oh my god I am
really struggling guys I forgot how
angry this game makes mark just on a
face look it's fine but also I'm really
struggling wait how are we ever gonna
get out of here okay that's a good
question I don't know how we are
oh my god no no no where am i where am i
I got a chest guys yeah chests good
choppa thanks bud and a heart oh there's
a heart in it I can't get any oh where
do I get it give me let me just give me
the heart that's all you do let me get
the heart I think my strategy of
constantly holding down the button is
really hindering my ability to play this
version of the game okay I'm doing great
guys I'm getting it back into oh I'm
doing great I'm doing great guys where
are you how do I keep getting separated
from you guys know this we don't want to
come over here yet don't come to where
we are it's not worth it if you find the
door more just take it what do you mean
if you find the way out
leave ow you're stuck in a pit of
sadness don't like you guys relying on
me it's I feel like it's all on you mark
I found the exit guys do you want me to
take it freak on shake yes hand I gotta
explore a little bit more this gold no I
mean there's some gold hang on hang on I
can do this wait there's a heart oh god
no oh no wait hi oh so good thing I went
down here guys it was a chest okay I can
never get this just locked we need a key
what do you mean this you need a key
there's a oh no that's the door we came
in here with Bob another [ __ ] I'm gonna
should I go in the door if you can yeah
oh I can all right
maybe oh god I don't know wait mister
form no okay
okay I got it oh okay there's another
130 oh oh there's death crystals
oh my goodness
why was there a plane crash sound what
was that that was the swamp doing I've
done 100
I am also down to one heart Oh Oh
everything is frozen we got a power up
oh I died I'm sorry I will never forgive
is this a boss oh god it's big oh no
it's fine free me release me how do i
sorry guys I got me freakin well I died
- lava lava
oh that's entirely my bad I could not
get away from the lava lava in this game
apparently is lava do we get to start
over on the same level or where are we
it looks like it's brand-new
Oh God oh yeah we start with no okay all
right we dodged that one I got hurt I
got I got that's triple jump I think
yeah yeah you did Bob you sure did was
that said not should I not have done
that no you did no I'm proud of you man
I'm proud of you you really did me pray
at the exit
can't we do it dad how's it going huh
careful there's spikes did you guys know
they're spikes
yeah go go go go go oh thank god oh good
could have saved ourselves a couple
hearts there oh we got hit I'm sorry
oh there's things careful the crystals
ah the crystals I'm bouncing yeah Oh God
oh okay Bob we gotta get this coin
without dying I'm just gonna give up on
it I'm fine oh thank you Oh God hit it
again oh god oh god oh god no no no no
no no no is it animal you're - oh god I
can't let go of the jump button I just
physically can't you know I can't I
don't know I I know it's against your
personal beliefs and I forgive you
so many goodies wait sideways what hell
no guys guys oh oh I'm sorry
you know what buddy you tried and that's
really what matter I don't think I did
what does this goop mean okay take
damage from the crystal but I'm a wizard
and I just want everyone to appreciate
how about the grizzle I hit it mark yes
could you not do that I know crystals
crystals here his crystals everywhere
they're great don't be deceived there's
a lot of crystals everywhere okay oh god
I panic because it was an animal and I
killed it there's a lot of blood ever no
damage to the starting crystal because
I'm an idiot
I think we should take the excess I've
got one heart missing okay me too me too
me too me too we're doing so good guys
oh god no oh no no not like this please
there's so much bad damage this game is
not easier or fun it turns out it's very
difficult actually there's a key there's
a key slot down here a key slot you say
I do say what do you mean here we go can
I please f do you you got it Bob you
guys please what's going on I found the
key but I'm stuck in a pit of hell
okay that's the area where you're stuck
over here wait oh geez oh no no oh I'm
not the key
yeah the form is not so hey Mark Oh oh
my god I didn't realize that what
happened oh I'm stuck in the oh there's
a chest now well I was going to a secret
up crushed by a swamp oh god I had the
key I did so good and then I rubbed the
swamp to death thinking I found a secret
you were so proud of yourself internally
I really was I took damage from that
what the little swirly boxes do damage
to you if you let your body touch them
oh well that's stupid there's a heart
over here I might need that but unless
I'm down one I can just take him mark
would be the one I would assume would be
to hurt okay all right that's a little
presumptive being honest no I grew
thought why he's being honest No Oh
infinite infinite gun
oh nice okay this is helpful it's
definitely helpful really helpful very
helpful
I see I see I see
oh wait what what huh what what is this
whoa every jumps to super job be careful
yeah should we do the door oh there's a
heart there's our there's Arthur's okay
okay easy easy just easy it doesn't mean
you have to go job is a super job ah
you're freaking I forgot already somehow
oh Jesus
okay that's really a fast one gotcha
[ __ ]
alright murders another pink little [ __ ]
that was trying to shoot at us nice
crystal mark the crystals hurt you I
don't know if you've experienced that
yet well it's your dry wit that I love
oh my god good murder
great murder hard over here mark if you
can get to us those hot okay thank you
okay be okay Wade got him I am a brute
that one let's all up where is it is it
right at the top of this dude at all
touch it Wade touch it you have to touch
it harder I think I'm not sure maybe
that's not the key for that it's gotta
be the key for that what are you talking
about use your X or B or something I
don't know I'm holding the key how do i
yeah bounce off of it that we're trying
to go try this I'll try to Pogo off of
it ooh that's worse somehow what would
you do using a super job it was just a
regular Pogo off of it and he killed
that bug for you guys everything's fine
we'll have the infinite anymore no cuz
you touched the time what oh I don't
know if you got hearts here there's a
swamp under that one be careful I see it
that's a big it's a fake thwomp it's not
real
oh he's not we're in the toy we're in
it's all I think we're invincible I
think we're invincible
are we invincible we are yeah we're not
for long
Oh God keep going oh Jesus you gotta
shoot it wait you gotta choke yeah okay
this is unhelpful Oh Oh God to go by oh
okay well [ __ ] all that I'm down to one
heart great me too
oh boy don't know oh my god oh I swear
God okay crystals left crystals left
side careful oh my god please for the
love of God as the thwomp careful god
dammit I am trying so desperately to oh
god oh my good oh my god oh my god oh
god please oh my god oh god please no oh
all the crystals know why that one who
got the super jump I think I touched the
gravity it lightly low gravity or
whatever this is I died again
god damn wall we we had a good run we
could run yeah we're at a hundred and
eighteenth
that's pretty good but I know we can do
better I think we ho invincible oh hey
Bob you both came tumbling back down oh
I got something else
didn't mean to but it happened later
okay I'm coming back
besides cleared wait now you're stuck in
hell oh don't come in here
what say yes god don't is it treasure
treasure treasure what's in there Bills
Bills oh it's just a bit what did you
think it was a I'm out I got it
what you guys suck oh [ __ ] are you doing
that you just got a jump shoot flip jump
easy you got a build momentum sure well
I'm sorry what get jump shoot flip jump
jump
flip flip Oh mark you complain about
being bad at this game if you get out of
here like half a second what's your
problem
jump shoot jump shoot you'll just keep
going you don't even need to flip just
jump and shoot oh oh it's easy I'm stuck
now come on save your light low I saved
your life Oh looks like I found the door
please take it just get us out of here
but there's gold over here I want some
all right forget the gold
I got let's just end this shall we all
right yeah
this is enough suffering I don't think
it's ever enough suffering a damn it
it's so hard to like break a block
that's directly sideways from you yes it
is I'm holding a key my dudes ooh that
always has helped us and never hindered
us
I found a heart but it's in a really
hard place to get for someone of your
skill level sorry I got it I ended up
getting it there's another part oh I got
that one too I'm sorry
I there was two hearts I didn't even
need that one I was full of arity of
your apologies that legitimately I
didn't mean to the other one I was like
ma'am I get it but the other one I found
the keyhole it's over here where all the
hearts were trapped in a hole with the
key hang on okay Bob crystal absolve I'm
not concerned with crew does that banana
hurt me no does that hurt me I'm not
gonna wait or go in the door go in the
door just go in the door Oh
oh my god there's no hearts here oops oh
god oh I am assuming this is safe why
would you assume that
whoa I'm really sorry about that one
guys what happened a mark can you give
me I got you did I didn't just get laser
it oh yeah the lava hurts
oh god no laser say right now right oh
this is very oh we had a perfectly nice
shower up and then we get this one Oh
goddamnit gonna stop doing that Ness
wait oh okay okay
all is well oh my poor part wait you'd
have to worry about it's a heart down
here if you guys want it I'm good I got
it I got it
I heart our way to hate this power up I
hate it you're drunk no I know but it's
even so know how hard this is
eyeball it aha the exit ticket please
you wanna leave there's a crystal right
up there don't come down here where else
Wow God dad oh good there's a murder
very how guys I gotta say we're not
actually gaining any ground on any of
the other people who play this game oh
god there's so many of you I killed that
ladybug
there's so many all right 1950s mommy
sees a mouse it was bad yeah I'm aware
I've been trying to deal with the mumps
can we ride the boom box Oh God just let
me get that hard guys let me get it
there we go wait you were going right
for it like the stupid ladybug it's not
okay that's good I guess there's an
extra hard at mark did you take it yeah
I have it no oh oh I'm riding the boom
box
a minute nerds oh we're all doing
damningly why can't why is this
impossible this is this is just a simple
platform there we go got it
No oh god oh god it's impossible why is
this impossible it's just a boom box why
is it impossible well I got it guys I
got it you don't have to come up here
don't worry I'm coming up this is a
point of pride down I did it burp
take it take it we all have to do it
your job mark you did it even though as
well after I already had done it yeah we
have to break this box and kill this
armadillo from the platform now got it
all right look look a fearless leader
mark over here that's me that's me oh my
god that was super nice over here do not
oh my god there's ice and you slide down
it oh god I don't like that I can't I
get over this home I fell a long way and
I was close to getting some jewels
Oh somebody needs to get out of this
hole of incapable did anyone get the gem
that dropped down there okay cool I'm
going in the exit okay yes please I need
a heart a lot of lava lava lava Aybar
that's your way there's nothing on the
other side it's not worth going for
there's a heart over here guys why I got
bounced into the lava blowing [ __ ] to
kill me I think I know who's holding us
back guys fine
shotgun frickin hello it's triple shot
shotgun oh god oh god please get me out
of this oh my god help me help me one of
you kill him yeah just shotgun mark I
just made dead-dead a million ways never
family gone forever I'll destroy your
entire world what kind of first level is
this
Oh push it Hey alright I got the gym
whoever whoever said no I might have
farted that down your way oh you think
I'm here yeah let's leave Oh frickin
stupid self you know so stupid at
everything for a few seconds I'm like
hey this is kind of fun and then I
remember oh yeah it's Pogo stuck like
sideways you [ __ ] no not like this oh
sorry who did it this time I blame Wade
what's the heart now we only go this way
around it hey that's my heart let me
know hey look there's a big heart over
here okay there's a big heart so if you
want it now I'm gonna take it there are
many like it but I'm taking it you know
what just for that we've opted you die
wait what happened I was a babe in
myself right in front of you I didn't
see it back to the purple box thing on
yeah yeah I'll be there just gonna not
play like me don't pull away here now
and I'm already out of lives so came
into this box that doesn't have anything
worth those goddamn door in this right
here go through it please there might be
some more secrets go I won't kill myself
I will end this run right now just death
leave do that bounce dude thank you man
oh wait don't you die almost touch it
don't touch it whatever you do oh that's
not a way you can go oh god how do we
get out of here
got it what are you gonna do you don't
have to flip don't try to flip I should
have lived I'm fine
no I'm not fine
oh sure oh god I got hate this game so
no they're just gonna murder I don't
know about this Pokemon guys this is
real funny went murder murder murder I
will be here you don't get to just be a
lazy garbage no contribute or or did you
go upper left I went up Oh God give me
the goddamn chest okay
got the chest we're doing great guys
there it is
oh why why God mark for God's sake get
us out of here hang on this stuff up
here there might be something good oh
there might be something good no mark
there might be something good oh there's
coins coins coins guys I'm just staying
here Bart this coin for coins mark
you're the only one that can do it now
I'm down and back down here in hell
Oh God no not like this please Oh God Oh
God I've go toe to toe with this
armadillo he's kicking my ass okay I'm
fine okay Hey look I was touching my
thumb stick no wait I would need that
marginally more than you because I don't
have one up
well I've died anyway oh god oh god this
is not worth it was worthless I really
do hey do I score
[Applause]
it was so bad you should have said it
louder and more emphatically with how I
got hurt already
how'd you get hurt there's a dill oh I
can't take the dillos man you just got a
man oh yeah just build okay all right
thanks man
wait this is secrets mark look at this
secret here there's no secret you're
lying to me but I'm coming anyway
parallax background and there's a hole
this is so obviously secrets so there's
always a parallax background yeah right
here oh that's not near a mess honey
shut it I wish I never tell a friend to
shut up because it's rude shut up you
have told me to shut up so I hey I
didn't tell my friend shut up all the
time I'm we're friends don't worry about
it shut up with you oh my god please
don't be enemies is it hurting there's a
heart I'm getting super jump avoid super
jump aboard you aw
you got it you really nailed that one
man did all that stuff so fast all in a
sequentially even I'm just going in I'm
just going in you guys say there was a
chest over there I just seen it what did
you say you found a chess because I
didn't have the information
listen whose fault is it then
no one's it's it's a product of
circumstance ways to blame okay are we
in a pit of so hey Mark hey bud I got
everything here what are you guys doing
here why are you down there guys what's
good I don't know man I just like
crystals being near them why are you
kidding me I know it was all Jim I don't
want to do it no more Oh Oh what you
want to do is poco you're way out of the
hole
oh gosh darnit no God the same God
there's a crystal up here and it's
really mad at me okay made it made it
made it made it made it all on you what
a minute
never mind I'm out I'm out of here hi
know what this is a key right yes no my
hand it was to the right of the entrance
over here oh good
yeah Pogo right on that bad boy just
come on Frick fricking now got him take
us so dead dude murder nice murder I
just want you guys to leave there's a
heart here but I'm not moving all right
you want the you don't have a life mark
you on it control or down I'll go try to
kill these things if I get your what I
say let me see I think marks killing it
right now I got it I got it seriously
though I think if you get the heart it
might give you a one-up you should get
it I don't think that's it I don't know
how I got another life then Oh God okay
so the exit we have this [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah yeah
what it was just to the left yeah you
land on brakes and there's a million
enemies I hit all of them oh don't
I've got a key oh all of that for
freakin okay well this is a trap don't
come down here I don't know that there
is a way back out I found where the key
hole goes
you need a car ski or you want me to go
ahead one Jemmy she was calling I really
don't think there's a way out of here oh
my god boss oh hey no God I can't hit it
for the life of me oh god I'm panicking
oh geez wait why am i what's wrong
what's happening what's happening
got a heart as soon as I hit some oh I
don't understand
Oh God
there's love over here where I am don't
come to that oh god please
oh why oh baby it is possible because
the mushroom that's a soup oh god I'm
gonna lose
boss come on just get it one more time
oh please one more time oh it's a show
oh my god hey Mark what's up good work
bud thanks hey pop me oh my god I can't
touch a goddamn thing
careful careful I'm down bottom right
I'm down the bottom right I'll come to
you I'll come to you just chill just
chill there's some lava over here it's
not so alright Bob your healthiest
member what does that mean we trust you
with our lives
not good okay I got something Bob no hey
Jesus the ladybugs hey 42nd we're doing
so good guys I'm gonna hey armadillo
just get oh whoops okay I want to try to
go up I found the exit but I also got
hit twice I'm so good no I thought of
chest I'm just gonna oh it super jump
somebody got super jump it's always Wade
I'm here you can leave whenever there's
a wait there's a heart does anyone want
Bob but mark you members coming for god
I'm going soon as you get it let me know
and I'll jump us all dump our asses
right out of this okay just go I I guess
fair's fair I've done that I get it oh
okay it's oh it's unlimited Oh save my
life thank you for a limited oh I was
right
oh god I hate everything I found work he
goes do you guys have a key I have a key
hey there's a heart mark I don't need
you take it take it take it I don't need
it I have the key and it's gonna be a
little bit of a process to get to get
out of here I got it
there cuz you had infinite you had
infinite [ __ ] you've got infinite
[ __ ] all right we need a key oh wow
cool hey Mark do you want to come take
this key for me I don't think I can god
the keys in the crystal now no
struggling bad bad things bad coming
back oh my nose cuz I was dead
this knot came out you came out my nose
okay
snot came out my nose god damn it go I
hate these crystals so much this is not
our run guys I just wanted you to know
this is not oh my god okay there we go
you got that key I sure do easy to get
out here you have infinite [ __ ] to a
splash now watch as I do it okay never
mind why would you come down here safe
no God I'm just going for I'm just going
for it guys I'm just gonna go for it and
you guys are gonna thank me later did
you get out of here yeah I got another
your wizard I know you know I'm gonna
try last time I tried mark if you could
please reach the exit
[Laughter]
I'm not laughing at you mark I'm
laughing with you because I know you're
having a good time yeah you know they
call me good time mark another heart
here don't orbit don't over Medill don't
armadyl doh
we you have a top that broke the wall
there's a wall block and we're
collecting very interesting
I made it Wow good job man oh don't come
down all the way where um where am I
trying to go here oh I threaded those
ladybugs um this is this is a bad hole
that's what she said found the exit did
you go through it I'm really sad right
now
okay I'm going please go
okay don't go left that's my observation
oh oh god oh oh I was really needing
that here's the exit anyone need in time
nope please leave all right we have to
go right
don't go boom kill the blueberry got him
okay good shot yeah I'm gonna use the
triple boost while it exists oh how am I
not dead I'm 12 - my own question oh my
god okay this is impossible
okay [ __ ] it up yeah you messed us up
mark oh [ __ ] Jesus okay I'm safe we went
in a crazy ass direction and went really
oh god why did I show you I figured out
why it's so funny to me would you react
up with you're upset mark was could you
sound like that that meme of Michael
Scott from the office when he's like oh
god god no that's exactly that tone of
voice
thank you it's what I was going
that's what yeah I know that's what you
like to hear I share your sentiments
just killing armadillos just let's just
leave with a butthole laser you got the
exit just go for it no just so we'll
just leave whoever's there I'm at the
accident hang on Oh for the love of God
before everything goes horribly no stop
touching things okay it's going we're
going okay thanks why flip through a
ladybug we want to lava guys Boop
oh oh terrifying be very oh god oh god I
did not mean to get this Oh super jump
oh god oh no oh no I can't I cannot I
cannot line up oh not this no please not
like this guy Oh God
I'll free you my friend there we go so
many enemies jump ah it is the goddamn
worst okay god damn it just oh my god oh
my god just do something with your
invincibility other than fall oh god
there's a blueberry of doom down here
yes sir as I was trying desperately to
fight it and I couldn't land a single
goddamn shot the whole time I was
invincible look out he's shooting stuff
oh [ __ ] I hit him once okay jeez oh my
god this game doesn't make me anxious
the way like heave-ho does but it makes
me something makes me feel a certain way
that I'm not sure how I feel about
feeling that way you know what I mean
wheel wheel wheel why why why wheel
wheel over it
I got trickshots right now oh god no oh
oh
I'm gonna lose it for us I mark we're
all stuck in the same hole I don't think
it's hue of it but I'm doing on the cusp
of game over town yeah that's the thing
about it that sucks
Oh Jim there's a bug up there
okay mark okay I'm through I'm through
I'm through yeah there's a bug I know
oh my god is that a heart please give me
that hard I hit the bug wait no no I'm
out I'm out
go little Oh God okay I can get us out
of here I can get us out of here do it
wait I'm going I'm going trouble oh my
god
I'm gonna die I kill those down words
blueberry screams I think I gotta call
it there yeah that's fine
[Music]
you